after the first explosion
a second one then i mean then a third
and fourth each stronger than the other
this is where the blast took place
inside the nicuatoma
barracks one of the country's largest
military bases
people around for their lives
[Music]
others rushed the injured to hospitals
live on national television the reporter
asks is the baby dead
no she replies but her mother is
we don't know what happened this man
says everything is destroyed
the barracks were home to hundreds of
families the rebel people tried to pull
out survivors many
are feared dead including detainees
trapped in the barracks prison cells
hospitals quickly became overwhelmed and
called for urgent blood donations
i'm asking for your excellency's
assistance from our brother countries
and international organizations
to help the republic of equatorial
guinea in this lamentable situation we
have
we already have the coronavirus health
emergency and adding to that this
tragedy in the city of butter
on national tv the anchor read out a
statement from president
teodoro obiang he says negligence
in a dynamite depot located on the base
caused
the explosion
given the scale of the destruction and
in these times of low oil prices made
even worse by the kovid 19 pandemic
i call on the international community to
provide all the help and assistance
necessary
obiang has been in power for the last 42
years amassing
half a billion dollars in personal
wealth in this
oil-rich country but according to the
world bank
80 percent of the population live on
less than two dollars a day
his son deodorin is the country's vice
president
in charge of the military and the
barracks where the explosion took place
last year french court charged him with
embezzling state funds
with the court seizing his 107 million
dollar paris home
critics of the regime see in these
explosions
as yet another example of the obiang's
family's
continued neglect of the people of
equatorial guinea
nicholas honk al jazeera